alec castonguay à montréal emmanuelle
latraverse et athée roi michel si oger
montréal dont soir messieurs dames on
parle d'économie
d'abord on va voir les chiffres on vient
d'en parler avec adrian le chiffre pour
le mois de juillet croissance timide
mais croissance donc le canada qui est
sorti ou qui sort en tout cas assurément
de la récession on ne pouvait pas dire
que c'est une mauvaise nouvelle la
récession et ne pas dire que chasse une
bonne nouvelle niche elles n'ont
effectivement c'est une bonne nouvelle
pour le gouvernement qui va pouvoir dire
à partir de maintenant et vous voyez
c'est une récession technique qui était
causé comme on l'avait dit par le
secteur de l'énergie fonctionne pas bien
mais pour le reste économie canadienne
perform et ça va permettre peut-être
aussi au club plus politique de
nouvelles attaques contre justin trudeau
en disant bella
pourquoi on a besoin du déficit
exactement pourquoi il est de dire le
déficit qui est leur pas parce qu'on a
besoin de stimuler l'économie ce parce
que vaucher famille mais pas fait trop
de promesses
le seul moyen que ça balance à la fin ce
matin 10 e emmanuel sur l'économie et
mêmes on le voit aujourd'hui le secteur
manufacturier même qui reprend un peu de
vigueur donc ça donne des munitions aux
conservateurs c'est une évidence
oui très clairement eux qui tentent
depuis 60 jours ou plus de convaincre
les canadiens que leurs solutions et la
bonne qu'il faut pas paniquer être
patient que l'économie va reprendre
c'est comme si petit à petit les cartes
salling en leur faveur à ce chapitre là
oui ça leur donne aussi des nouvelles
munitions contre les libéraux pensent
que les libéraux sont surtout soulagé
que ces chiffres là ne soit pas sorti au
mois d'août eux font le pari et espère
probablement que leur discours sur le
changement sur le besoin de
transformation en profondeur est assez
percolé pour pouvoir minimiser l'impact
de ces de ces attaques là des
conservateurs mais c'est sûr que ça
complique le message de justin trudeau
c'était facile à dire vous voyez ça
prend des buts et on est en récession et
vous dire oui ça prend des députés il
faut réinvestir à plus long terme donc
que des bonnes nouvelles à
chapitre aux lettres de moyens
promotionnels pascal est qu on dira ce
qu'on voudra mais on y revient souvent
l'économie reste un facteur extrêmement
important dans la décision que les gens
prennent de voter pour un parti ou pour
l'eau où est la gestion de l'économie
est l'un des thèmes central de cette
campagne électorale donc c'est évident
que ces chiffres là aujourd'hui
oui ils sont positifs pour les
conservateurs mais quand même une limite
là on ne peut pas dire du côté du
gouvernement kan lorsque l'économie
performe bien c'est grâce à nous et
lorsque l'économie performa levé c'est
la conjoncture mondiale puis c'est pas
de notre faute c'est de la faute aux
autres
il faut qu'on soit quand même à la barre
parce que la tempête foule a traversé un
moment donné une limite la jouer ce jeu
là donc comme on n'était pas de la faute
du gouvernement conservateur selon les
dires de stephen harper de la récession
c'est un peu plus compliqué dit que
c'est grâce à lui maintenant que ça va
bien mais ceci dit c'est vrai que ça va
donner des munitions pour attaquer
essentiellement justin trudeau parce que
ça aide aussi le npd ça crédibilise son
son plan économique qui est de huy
réinvestir des trains pour un
gouvernement qui serait plus
progressistes mais en équilibrer le
budget lorsque l'économie vont un peu
mieux c'est plus facile d'équilibrer le
budget alors que justin trudeau comme le
dit emmanuel michel bain depuis le début
de la campagne dans la récession ont
frappé il faut stimuler l'économie
alors est-ce qu'on a encore besoin de
faire des déficits et stimule l'économie
alors que peut-être que la récession est
déjà derrière nous la j'ai essayé jeudi
nous avons essayé jeudi dernier de faire
parler les chefs de la santé je demande
à monsieur mulcair en trop et on voulait
des réponses de tout le monde et ce que
comment on peut promettre aux canadiens
sept mille médecins 200 cliniques alors
que celle des provinces qui gère la
santé oms n'a pas eu de réponse a été
l'accord souligné beaucoup aujourd'hui
justin trudeau est revenu sur ce thème
de la santé les soins à domicile pour
être répression les coudes pour vient un
nouveau gouvernement libéral accordera 3
milliards de dollars au cours des quatre
prochaines années pour améliorer et
adapter notre système de santé pour
qu'il soit viable malgré le
vieillissement de la population
notre priorité sera d'établir une
stratégie de soins à domicile moderne
pour les canadiens donc je repose la
question est là je suis ce genre de
réponse mais manuel
les soins à domicile c'est pas mal les
provinces comment dans le détail il
remet plus d'argent province et tout
quoi oui les soins 2007 patrice c'est
surtout une tranche de l'électorat sur
laquelle dont ont besoin tous les partis
politiques c'est le vote des aînés c'est
des gens qui votent qui se mobilisent et
cetera donc ça passe par là moi ce que
j'ai remarqué dans l' annonce de justin
trudeau c'est bien beau de remettre 3
milliards on va renégocier avec les
provinces
une nouvelle entente sur le financement
de la santé ça fait des années que les
partis d'opposition tape sur la tête du
gouvernement a peur à cause de la
formule que lui a retenu pour bonifier
les transferts en santé pour mac rae que
justin trudeau aujourd'hui ne s'est pas
engagé à retourner à la formule paul
martin qui est d'augmenter les
transferts de 6 % par année dont on veut
négocier ça avec les provinces on verra
donc ya encore beaucoup de flou
peut-être à ce chapitre quant à la
nature de l'offre que vont mettre sur la
queue mettrait sur la table un éventuel
gouvernement libéral uni où les
néo-démocrates même lorsque la dans ses
négociations avec avec l'épreuve avec
les provinces michel c'est le domaine
des provinces
s'il de même des provinces puis un
transfert en santé c'est supposé être
inconditionnel
c'est ce que vous êtes un chèque et la
province administre le programme local
monsieur trudeau 10 au 23 milliards sur
les soins à domicile
bon ça reste et il a plu par toutes les
provinces va le faire de choix d'aimer
c'est sûr que c'est une voie d'avenir
c'est pas mal mieux d'avoir déjà une
policière
bah oui la population vieillit c'est la
première fois que plus de vivre de
jeunes oui mais une fois qu'on a dit ça
s'arrête aux provinces a organisé le
système des systèmes sont organisées de
façon différente des institutions
différentes de celles ci au québec en a
pas ailleurs
alors
où les transferts sont inconditionnels
où ils sont conditionnels psy sont
conditionnels ça veut dire de la chicane
ça peut pas être autrement alors quand
je me suis mal qu'un apprend on l'a vu
dans son cadre financier promettait des
dents les fêtes des transferts
conditionnels on a dit ce n'est pas une
très bonne façon de procéder aux oiseaux
la même chose en comme les autres une
houle alec et les politiciens fédéraux
ont toujours la tentation de faire des
promesses qui touchent des domaines qui
sont près des gens vous savez le
gouvernement fédéral ce que des affaires
étrangères la gestion des finances
publiques du commerce international rien
de très sexy en campagne électorale
rinne qui touche les genres la santé un
peu comme celles liées au provincial ça
touche les gens l'éducation ça touche
les gens mais c'est pas du domaine de
compétence fédérale donc on s'immisce le
plus loin qu'on peut du côté des partis
fédéraux ta maman aucun doute et on va
promettre des infirmières des indes et
des médecins des cliniques
justin trudeau soit un demi sel en
réalité les deux la ligne la plus
importante de ces communiqués de presse
le sait après avoir fait une entente
avec les provinces sur le sujet parce
que c'est ce grand la clé comment on
s'entend avec les provinces
on peut bien annoncé des médecins des
infirmières des soins domicile c'est les
provinces qui décide c'est le chèque qui
fait foi de tout et ça c'est toujours
pas négocier voilà reparlons j'allais
dire à contrecoeur mais je ne dirais pas
mais repart du niqab une seconde parce
que les chefs ont dû re par l'état
aujourd'hui compte tenu bon hier on a
parlé ensemble de la statistique qui
veut que deux femmes auraient été
touchés par cette histoire là aurait
refusé d'enlever leur niqab pendant les
cérémonies d'assermentation il y en a
plus peut-être mais bon bref est-ce que
ça va arrêter ou a remarqué que c'est de
notre faute
allez me dire non pour des questions un
michel exactement la raison pour
laquelle on en parle si vous voulez me
pose une question là dessus
un moment donné est-ce que deux
personnes valent qu'on fasse dès qu'on
fasse dérailler une campagne électorale
là dessus ça la question était posée je
maintiens aujourd'hui comme des vétérans
arrête d'en parler la poudre
on n'en sortira pas d'accord mais ya
quand même il ya un débat intéressant
autour de ce qu'on donne des services
voilée est ce qu'on les reçoive où aller
ou pas de façon générale williams a des
bonnes et il va se faire devant les
tribunaux il ne faut pas dans l'opinion
publique sait pas c'est pas être
publiquement un vote la tuerait bien
j'apparais puis à michel patry ces clics
les conservateurs qui sont les premiers
à dos reparler de ça monsieur lebel
aujourd'hui toi moi les gens m'en
parlent on va en parler c'est bien c'est
bien on va voir si monsieur peuvent en
parler dans son discours à québec ce
soir mes yeux quand même foyer de
services à visage découvert n'ose pas
aller aussi loin parce que c'est des
bobs beaucoup plus large on est bien
content de frapper sur le cloud du
serment convient canadiens pourquoi
parce que c'est symbolique et on peut
justement lier cela à des valeurs sens
prendre le risque d'un débat beaucoup
plus larges comme celui auquel vous
faites allusion
vous êtes obligé d'en parler avec mes
souvenirs je donne 10 56 exemple à
écouter de mots pour dire
qu'effectivement emmanuel raison le
gouvernement qui ici à cheval sur les
valeurs canadiennes pour le serment tout
à fait d'accord qui est des
fonctionnaires qui portent le niqab qui
servent les citoyens avec le niqab ou
qui reçoivent des services du
gouvernement avec le niqab donc en
termes de principes on est déjà vu un
peu plus cohérent
et l'autre chose c'est que oui le débat
est intéressant oui le débat important
est important il méritait qu'on en parle
ceci dit il faut relativiser au moment
donné qu'on l'ait rendu à deux femmes
sur 690 personnes d'achat est ce que le
vaudois est impressionné par ce jeu un
peu moins certaines intentions de vote
on lâche le niqab intentions de vote au
canada
on va voir 21 23 septembre par rapport à
l'autre semaine 26 cette semaine 26 et
29 7 ans voyez les libéraux c'est une
annonce on compare des oranges et des
oranges nano ce qu'ils montrent une
montée des libéraux conservateurs montée
des conservateurs et le npd une chute
jeunes [ __ ] le bloc qui a augmenté aussi
évidemment ça c'est ces canadiens et un
autre bon on les a vus ces séries
attendez avant l'autre tableau en jeu
juste vous entendre sur le premier
moi je ne me souviens pas puis s'il ya
de bonnes raisons parce que je pensais
jamais arrivé qu'une corps soit aussi
serré à trois au canada là vraiment
c'est on est dans du il faut le
souligner on est là il ya plus de cartes
routières la partir de maine
non non c'est du jamais vu et non
seulement c'est du jamais vu patrice
mais on ne sait pas ce que ça va donner
quand les jaunes vont être ouvertes
parce que c'est ça aussi le problème une
lutte à trois à quatre dans certains cas
au québec en particulier puis ou en
colombie britannique avec les verts ça
peut donner un peu n'importe quoi on
peut avoir beaucoup de contre x ce qui
ce qui se dessine par 200 300 voix qui
vous savez le soir des élections on va
travailler tard c'est ça que ça veut
dire
on en sort on relate la tendance se
maintient va pas être donné à 8h30 là
mais vous serez avec nous ben oui vous 3
vous serez tous avec côté je veux que je
commente avant la récréation
je veux qu'on montre le dernier tableau
à ça c'était un facteur fort important
quels chefs d'opposition propose le
changement que vous voulez on prétend
que 70 % des canadiens 68 pour être
exact veulent du changement dans cette
élection
regardez bien en ontario c'est justin
trudeau qui remporte c'est lui le quai
carnot changement en majorité au québec
c'est thomas mulcair
quand le britannique justin trudeau
également vous a montré ces trois
provinces là parce qu'elles sont
importantes évidemment dans le
dénouement du vote qu est ce que ça vous
dit ça alec d'abord le seul chiffre qui
m'apparaît étonnant c'est celui de la
colombie britannique c'est à dire qu'au
québec que le npd soit le facteur de
changement son pull concevoir malgré la
semaine difficile qu'ils ont connus sont
encore premier dans les intentions de
vote en ontario c'est justin trudeau qui
chauffent les conservateurs et donc
c'est logique qu'il soit perçu comme le
véhicule de changement
colombie-britannique stampe étonnant
parce que le npd qui promit ou
quitteraient cyril avec le parti
conservateur et les libéraux sont
souvent troisième dans les intentions de
vote or si on se fie à ces chiffres le
brut les championnats jette un peu plus
bas en colombie-britannique le faut
faire attention mais sinon si on se fie
à ça ça voudrait dire que justin trudeau
pourrait d'ici la fin de la campagne
peut-être remonter légèrement qu'on le
met britannique parce que pour l'instant
ce n'est pas tout à fait d'accord avec
les chiffres d'intentions de vote mais
ce qui est clair
je le pense depuis un bon moment que
dans la dernière semaine et demie les
sondages vont être très importants les
anti harper ils sont très nombreux très
nombreux le vous parlez de 68 à 69 5 ils
vont ils vont se chercher un champion
est bon je cherche un endroit où
admettre leur vote pour pouvoir battre
stephen harper on est encore dans la
tente de savoir qui va être le champion
là mais je pense qu'il va voir un
mouvement de assez important qui peut se
produire dans les dix derniers jours de
la campagne
dix secondes chacun manuel michel c'est
vraiment là les beaucoup de gens qui
magasinent encore qui incarne le
changement c'est le duel à finir si vous
voulez qu'ils durent moi je pense que
locke tout le monde est en préparation
du dernier débat de vendredi
mais attendez vous en début de semaine
prochaine pendant trois quatre jours
avoir un [ __ ] libéraux mettent le paquet
pour réussir à faire bouger juste assez
les intentions de vote pour espérer
créer un mouvement dit si d'ici le 19
michel ce qu'on voit le les chiffres de
colombie-britannique ça veut dire qu'il
ya du vote stratégique qui est déjà
commencé là-bas on commence déjà à dirab
ainsi s'il faut je voterai pas pour le
npd que je préfère je vais voter pour
trudeau parce que mon but c'est de
battre stephen dans les plats il va y en
avoir beaucoup au jeu d'accord avec elle
et qu'il va y avoir beaucoup de vent
stratégique dans ce texte on a ce que
j'aime dans ce panel politique c'est que
je réponds à certaines personnes qui
nous parle puis les gens nous en parlent
beaucoup de jeunes populaires messieurs
dames
ce que j'aime c'est qu'on parle autant
de stratégies que de contenu on a parlé
de santé on a parlé d'économie
puis bien sûr dans un panel politique on
parle de stratégie politique ça fait
partie de cette histoire qui est en
train de se jouer
messieurs dames à demain que ça lui a lu
roi